alright welcome to the program we are
back from vacation we'll have a lot of
new stuff happening for you this week
and where I want to start today is I
want to talk about the future of the
United States but not I mean the Trump
is part of it but that's not really what
this story is about I know that now when
we talk about the future of the country
very often it relates to Donald Trump
has Donald Trump irreparably done a B or
C or how will we recover from de F that
Donald Trump is done that's not really
what this is about this is this is a
bigger picture story but importantly
it's also not about predicting the
future in any particular sense humans
are notoriously bad at predicting the
future it's not just economists I'm
talking about we've talked about how
economists are bad at predicting the
future of the economy but with change
happening more and more quickly
predictions about what humanity will be
like or what the United States will be
like in 50 years in a hundred years in
500 years it's increasingly pointless to
do that type of thing any predictions
about this will definitely be or this
will never be these are not useful
predictions to make so for example when
Donald Trump said during his last State
of the Union address that the United
States will never be a communist country
and maybe he used the word socialist and
everybody cheered Republicans cheered
other than that being a really ignorant
thing to say because there's really no
risk of that happening in the immediate
like the idea that the country is on the
verge of becoming a socialist country
that's not the case to say something
will never happen makes very little
sense because it's 500 years is a long
time a hundred years is a long time fair
enough I think we understand that what
this story is about is about the future
of the American political system now
there is no doubt that many of us
believe elements of the current system
are unstable and precarious and at some
point it could be natural to think the
system will collapse or evolve and many
people feel that there is an
inevitability to that so I'll give you
some specific examples Marxists have
long held that eventually the prole
Harriett is going to revolt against the
bourgeoisie in capitalist countries like
the united states the system will
collapse and in its place will be
installed a Marxist system of government
okay that's an example of a Marxist idea
of the inevitability of what will be the
future political system free-market
capitalists on the other hand who
believe that the ideas of social
democracy are fraught untenable bad
ideas the free market capitalists often
imagine that as those ideas fail be it
single-payer health care or whatever
society will move more and more in the
direction of total free-market
capitalism more generally history has
shown us that nation-states often don't
last forever right whether we're talking
about the fall of Rome or the Ottoman
Empire or there are many other examples
and it is true a country can be
destroyed by war a country can be taken
over it can be annexed it can be divided
up into multiple smaller countries as we
saw happen during the 1990s in Europe
for example but it's important for any
good activist to understand that it's
called the status quo for a reason and
things can basically remain as they are
and this is actually a desired outcome
this is a goal for many elements of
society that wield influence and I'll
explain what I mean because this is
really important stuff to understand we
look at health care in the United States
and we look at medical bankruptcy the
increased cost of health insurance the
terrible plans that cost you know five
hundred bucks a month for a ten thousand
dollar per year deductible or whatever
and we think this can't go on forever
like eventually this has to collapse but
maybe not there are very powerful
interests that want the system to
basically remain this way but they
recognize that it's not sustainable
indefinitely in other words we say this
is not indefinitely sustainable those
who want the current system also
recognize it's not indefinitely
sustainable if the trajectory continues
and they
choose to do just enough to keep
basically the same system going I'll
give you another example we look at the
cost of college which has skyrocketed
some college is costing sixty seventy
eighty thousand dollars a year maybe my
numbers are outdated and it's even more
we project out that growth and we say
this can't go on this is a system that's
going to implode on itself because
college will soon cost hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year people won't
be able to afford it or they'll take out
student loans which they will never be
able to pay because wages are not
increasing in parallel with the cost of
college so it'll collapse and we'll
start over hopefully with something
better or the powers that be which
include colleges student lending
institutions and others can tweak what
we have put in some subsidies raise
wages a little bit to make expensive
college degrees just slightly more worth
it to basically perpetuate the system
that we have now of huge profits for
lenders schools and students who get
degrees with which they can't really get
ahead and take decades to pay the loans
off if they ever are able to pay them
off the entire point here is the
assumption that an unsustainable system
will collapse that then we can change
into something we like ignores that the
status quo is not only appealing to many
systems of power
but that it will be a great motivator to
them to fix little things to avoid the
collapse just to perpetuate the status
quo this is how they will throw bones to
the masses every once in a while this is
part of the same system that prevents
people from being able to afford really
getting out there and protesting big
time for massive systemic change the
system works to keep people so day to
day when it comes to their salaries that
they can't take time off to go and
protest but then if things get too hot
they will throw us a bone here or there
things can basically stay the same or
close to it for a long time and as I've
said before it's always harder to win
when you want to do stuff and the other
side wants to keep things the same but
knowing this bad
arms us to be activists we're working
against we're working against my
pronunciation was a little bit incorrect
there we're working against not just
people who want to change things for the
worse
for the most number of people but there
are huge forces that we are fighting
that merely want to tweak the edges to
basically maintain the status quo that
includes corporate powers and it
includes moneyed interests so understand
that the collapse is not inevitable
because the strategy is doing just
enough to avoid the collapse but
basically perpetuate the status quo and
a big part of this is economics and
we're going to dig into some economics
next